[Music]
of all the polarizing issues in politics
today and yes there are many the climate
change debate is right at the top of the
list climate change seems to be one of
the you're either with us or you're
against us topics usually debated by
people immediately taking a partisan
stance rather than a well-thought-out
position this past year I actually lost
a good friend who told me that she could
no longer be associated with people who
even debate climate change and I'm
someone who's had such conversations on
this very show I think the most hate
that I ever got for a Rubin report
episode was when I had Alex Epstein
author of the moral case for fossil
fuels and for a sit down
Alex's argument isn't against manmade
climate change specifically instead he's
more focused on how to increase human
prosperity with what we have now
essentially his argument is although
climate change could be real fossil
fuels still have many net benefits for
our society after endless tweets emails
and messages from angry people Alex did
a follow up video on YouTube himself
where he answered around a hundred
viewer questions engaging with people
who have different views is exactly what
the battle of ideas is all about on the
flip side of the debate
I've also sat down with Michael Mann a
climatologist and the author of the
famous the hockey stick and the climate
Wars who's a thought leader in the
climate change debate I've discussed
climate change to some degree or another
with believers in manmade climate change
like sam Harris Michael Shermer and
Richard Dawkins as well as some with the
more skeptical views such as Andrew
Clavin steven crowder and ben shapiro
and for the record not one of these
guests believe the exact same thing as
anyone else i just mentioned right there
I find climate change to be a really
interesting discussion because it often
shows how one's thinking works in other
areas as well
generally speaking Democrats are those
on the left see climate change as
man-made and believe that governmental
action is the best or in some cases the
only way to reverse its negative effects
Republicans are those on the right
generally believe that something is
happening to the environment though
there is some debate as to whether it's
man-made
but regardless believe that the private
sector is better left to deal with these
issues of course there are outliers on
each side such as
my former guests California Democratic
gubernatorial candidate Mike
Shellenberger who wants the private
sector to be more involved in solving
climate issues and at the same time
there are also Republicans and people on
the right who deny manmade climate
change at all the science debate on
climate change is an interesting one and
one in which I'm happy to have what
interests me more though is how the
government should or should not be part
of the solution to whatever the problem
may be you know my feelings on this that
the government is rarely the solution to
anything actually at this point I think
the government is usually the problem in
the first place and I'd always rather
exhaust private options before turning
to the government especially the federal
government ironically this should be the
position of the people who hate Trump
why would you want to keep giving the
government more power when you hate the
guy in charge but at the end of the day
it's not governmental power that they
have a problem with it's that they only
have a problem with governmental power
when it's not their guy at charge
fortunately there does seem to be a
younger generation that is tackling
issues like climate change in the
environment in a totally new way it
seems to be based not only in scientific
facts but also in an understanding of
how a limited government should work my
guest this week is Benjy backer
president of the American conservation
coalition the group is dedicated to
finding new ways to look at old problems
as its mantra States they are committed
to efficient effective conservative
environmentalism as for me I'm a
believer in the science behind climate
change and the funny thing about science
is that it doesn't care whether you
believe in it or not for me the real
debate around climate change is how to
go about finding solutions without
giving more power and more money to the
government whether you believe in
climate science or not whether you want
more government regulation or less or
whether you believe the private sector
can find a solution or not we're all
stuck on this little rock together so
until Alan musk a private businessman
gets us all to Mars let's try to figure
out how to solve some of our problems on
this pale blue dot while we still have a
chance
[Music]
joining me today is the founder of the
American conservation coalition an
organization committed to efficient
effective conservative environmentalism
hashtag green GOP Benjy backer
welcome to the ruben reports great to be
here i feel you are long overdue
even though 20 years old you didn't have
a lot of time to get here but you know
you got here we've met a couple times i
kind of found out about you a couple
years ago we're gonna talk about what
kind of put you on the map in the
political world and got your activism
going and all that but it's good to have
you here i like that you you dressed
ready for the part oh yeah you gotta
gotta look good to feel good alright so
you have a really interesting story of
what got you in this mix but first i
thirst thought I'd like to ask my guest
just kind of tell me a little bit about
your upbringing yeah Emily that kind of
thing yeah so I grew up in a family of
five completely non-political very close
family we traveled a lot together
youngest I had two older sisters my
parents were actually entrepreneurs they
started a business when I was I want to
say ten which was a software company
based on mortgages and really started to
take off but it was during the recession
and it was a really bold move for that
time mine it really paid off and they're
now retired and kind of lived the
American dream which was a really cool
thing to be brought up by yeah what
about the politics at home were you guys
always kind of conservative or didn't
talk about it so actually you've got
really different views my sister is a
liberal one of them and then one of them
is more just not into it very much my
parents are conservative but they never
told us really about their views they
wanted us to decide for ourselves
obviously their morals and values I
think played into how I feel about
things but it was never forced upon us
or they were not adamant about politics
or volunteered or donated to my
knowledge two campaigns so I really
wasn't talked about in the house you
know they'd have the debates on or they
you'd have the news on but nothing
really more than that so I was able to
figure out my opinions for myself when I
was a little bit earlier than most
people when I was ten but yeah what kind
of pain
there's a ten-year-old have well I was
watching that John McCain Obama debates
which at ten years old yes at ten years
old I found it really interesting and I
wanted to figure out where I stood on
the spectrum of what I support John
McCain or what I support I think Senator
Obama at the time yeah and so I looked
up online kind of just a basic outline
of what each side believed in and I
figured out that I was conservative and
so for that couple years I kind of I I
forced my parents to put signs in our
yard for John McCain I forced them to
put bumper stickers on our cars
what are you various what did your
parents think about this their tenure
like all right well support you in
whatever you do they were very I mean
it's it's I think that they were
surprised and now I don't know if any
parent thinks that their ten-year-old
kid is gonna get super interested in
politics because it doesn't relie affect
you at ten years old it doesn't really
affect you until after college really so
that was kind of a surprise to them but
they were supportive they let me you
know research as much as I wanted to and
again they allowed me to put the signs
in the yard the bumper stickers on my
rip stick you know that type of thing so
it was a pretty cool time and then I got
injured and decided to volunteer because
I couldn't play sports no all right so I
wanna I want to get to that in a sec but
wait I just want a picture this ten
years old you're watching me you guys
soon you're watching with your folks
probably er yeah right okay you go
online to figure out the issues what
mattered to you at ten years old that
you said at the end of it okay I'm a
conservative or I'm gonna vote for
McCain well my pet my parents were
always really fiscally conservative with
just how they spent money you know we
were never like in a really really tough
position when I was super young but we
always were saying you know buy the
cheapest product you can save as much
money as you can and that was something
that I was brought up with so that
really mattered to me and knowing that
the government could take away my
parents hard earned money and knowing
that the government could come in and
and harm my dad's business by putting a
ton of restrictions that kind of struck
me pretty harshly and then also my
family we were raised on family values
right you know close-knit family it
it kind of happens that way so those two
things were kind of the main drivers I
would say yeah it's just hard to imagine
a 10 year old baby but it's at but it's
pretty cool and it explains why you're
here right now so okay what put you on
the map and when I found out about you
and I think nationally when people found
out about yeah and now this makes sense
now that I know that this was brewing a
ten year ago 2013 you're 15 years old
yeah what happens yeah so I had been
active in politics for three years
before that and what does that even mean
well I was gone
carry on Scott Walker's campaign Senator
Ron Johnson s campaign I helped out Mitt
Romney as well in 2012 and people
believe it started throw up but could
people even believe it like here's this
12 year old kid 11 year old kid working
on these campaign it was actually really
funny the first campaign ever worked on
did let me use the phones at first
because they could you know we need to
try to do it twelve-year-old on the room
you can tell us like hi is Michael dress
there like yeah but like who are you and
why are you 12 and why are you calling
me from a congressional office right
crystal campaign and so people were
actually really surprised conservatives
were really supportive they're like whoa
look at this 12 year old kid is
volunteering for us and the left is like
why is this 12 year old and cheering for
them so it was pretty funny again I was
injured so I needed something to do in
like any twelve-year-old
I decided to volunteer for politics so
yeah it was a very interesting dynamic
because this is also hilarious that an
injury got you into politics what kind
of injury was an ankle injury that the
doctors couldn't figure out I was like
crutches for a year and a half
Wow gained a lot of weight it was during
middle school which does not help
because those are the worst years for
that anyways and so then again I went
into congressional office and they
didn't want me to do the phones they
don't want me to go door-to-door cuz
imagine a 12-year olds coming to your
door like hey you should vote for X Y or
Z like I might why should I trust a 12
year old right so this is a very
interesting dynamic at that age so all
right so now what puts you on the map
yes a 13 year 15 years old something
happens yes so in high school early on
in high school and middle school
teachers had really
come out for me for my political views
because I was trying to make local
headlines for my activism especially in
the recall election for Scott Walker in
2012
so tell me that tell me a little bit
about what your opinions were in what
your teachers were yes I was a really
pro scout Walker guy I was I actually
ended up becoming close with his family
and and a great guy but I even better
policies you know I talked to a lot of
teachers who were sick of being forced
to join unions and sick of starting out
with $30,000 base pay when senior senior
teachers were making $100,000 with
benefits and it took them 40 years to
get to that level even if they're a
better teacher so people were really
kind of sick of that but it was a very
small minority because the unions really
had a lot of brainwashing in the state
and I'm sure in other states as well and
so my view is that Scott Walker is
really helping out the state because he
helped balance the budget and he kind of
freed the teachers up and helped their
pay become more of a fair shake but they
the teachers did not like that the
majority of them I mean most people know
of the huge uprising that happened the
protests were there are thousands of
people death threats to every Republican
in the state legislature and the
governor and so the teachers would leave
school they protested they take leave
they would cry in class I mean it was it
was pretty insane yeah and then you know
you have me over here bold little Benjy
know when I was there and saying who
Scott Walker they did not like that at
all so they would say pretty disparaging
things to be in class in front of my
fellows like what kind of things would
they say to you they attacked my family
for being business owners and saying
that they were lazy and saying that they
assumed that my parents golf every
Friday by the way my parents don't know
how to golf so that's not true I don't
even know how I golf and so that was
that was one thing that that that they
would always say and they would call me
a racist or weird for being in politics
at such a young age
what's that like for for a kid of that
age I'd be dealing with that it's one
thing to be outspoken but I out your
teachers your authority figures are
attacking you publicly in school I
actually in a minute
because at first I was pretty taken
aback and I was kind of sad about it
but my parents really pushed me on and
said you're doing the right thing and
just kind of block out as the
Millennials say block out the haters
yeah so I didn't really care that much
as long as it didn't affect my grades or
how my classmates viewed me because I do
care about the people that I am friends
with so so that was kind of frustrating
but after a while I just kind of got
used to it because it would happen in a
class every single quarter of every
single semester of every single year 7th
grade until til I started coming out
nationally about this issue did it ever
affect your grades because I could see a
teacher in a subjective class maybe not
map where it would be tough to screw
with your grades but a social studies
teacher where you're writing an essay or
an English teacher or something actually
harming your grade it did actually my
lowest grade ever was in a social
studies class in middle school
I've never gotten anything really below
like a high B level and there I got a
d-plus Wow in that social studies class
it's middle school so at that point is
middle school so it didn't really matter
per se but you could say you can see
that there was a trend going and that
I'd be worried in the future years
whether or not that it would affect me
and in other classes I don't think it
did as much which is good but in that
class I did see I mean it's a pretty
obvious correlation between me getting
good grades in every class since that in
every class before then and then getting
a d-plus in that class right weird and
also probably not a coincidence that
social studies is the class that you
were probably talking about this right
the most right did you did you try to
fight the teacher on that did your folks
get involved or anything oh we actually
I actually ended up switching schools
Wow I mean it's incredible yeah so so
that was that was a big change it
actually ended up being for the better
because the school is switch to is one
the feeder school so the high school if
I was going to so I ended up making
better connections there but it was an
annoying change that shouldn't have been
necessary it was a teacher who had a
history of these types of behaviors not
just on politics but on other things so
so it's interesting because you were
fighting the unions which in your
estimation was actually Pro teacher
because you thought the union
were too powerful meanwhile you have
teachers fighting you which is really
only feeding your initial premise right
in the first place yeah so that was
really it really enhanced my opinion on
the subject it made me really want to to
push further because I could tell that
some of these teachers were really
worried about their job or their job
security because they knew that they
could actually be held accountable now
and some of the senior teachers knew
that oh I actually have to perform well
to get paid well I don't my age isn't
just the deciding factor yeah so I think
that that's why people came out so
strongly in certain areas so some people
just didn't really understand the full
scope of the situation and call them
down once they figured that out but some
I think were really worried about their
their future pay because they had kind
of just been relaxed for the last 20
years since their pay had gone up right
so basically they weren't doing a great
job and rice isn't just unique to
Wisconsin this is happen all over
America where you have these teachers
that have been at it forever I've kind
of given up or are not working that hard
anymore but they're protected by the
unions their salaries keep going up they
get great benefits etcetera etcetera
that's what you're fighting and you're
seeing the the fruits of what happens
with that as they're cracking down on
you so what actually put you on what was
the specific incident that that put this
all in motion yeah so I kind of took all
the information that I had of all the
experiences that I had gone through and
wrote it up in a blog for Freedom Works
it ended up going to Drudge and then
Todd Starnes at Fox wrote something up
about it
Town Hall had something it started to
get in that space and then eventually
Megyn Kelly's show reached out to ask me
to come on and talk about it so that
kind of put me on the map there and then
I started to be invited to conferences
to speak about my experience and kind of
how other young conservatives shouldn't
be scared to speak out in the classroom
even if their teachers or other fellow
students come after them
it wasn't easy because it was my
sophomore year of high school actually
my fresh end of my freshman year of high
school and the after that Fox News
interview I received death threats
people were threatening me at school
because some of the teachers that I had
called out which I never named their
names but I called them out they were
popular with the students
so people weren't happy about it so it
was it was not an easy time for my
family either yeah I want to focus on
that a little bit but I think because
everyone gets this these days and rice
is one of the themes of what we do here
is everyone's just like afraid to say
anything because they don't want to deal
they don't want to deal with just the
hate they get on Twitter and you got
plenty of that and that's how I found
you after this but but the other stuff
like you had to go to school the next
day so literally what what is that like
well I I don't have ever said this
publicly but I carried a knife at school
so I'm so scared
with my life and I didn't tell my
parents I had a friend give it to me
that was worried about my safety it was
a pretty hard time because no matter if
people think I was doing something right
or wrong I think part of the problem
with our culture and it was the same way
for years ago or five years ago is that
if someone's doing something you don't
agree with you're just gonna completely
attack them wholeheartedly without any
respect for what they're doing or their
opinions or anything like that and so I
was honestly scared for my life you know
I couldn't go anywhere I got my bike
stolen when I bike to an ice cream shop
and I live in a very safe place and it
was somebody from my high school that
just really didn't like me you know I'd
be walking my dogs and someone would
flip me off and say after you Benjy
backer you know suck up whatever what
about your family at that time because I
know you said your folks were always
backing you and telling you right do
what you believe in was there any
repercussions for them or their business
or anything like that no their business
was fine I think you know most most
adults who knew what was going on
treated me with a lot of respect I think
it is mostly the young people who who
were a little bit ignorant about what
was going on so my parents didn't have
any negative repercussions that I know
of
again they might have been not telling
me because they didn't want to make it
any worse for me because I don't know
that I care about them so that was that
was a tough time for them though because
they live through their kids and having
something like that be constantly going
after or keep people constantly going
after your son is not the greatest thing
in the world especially when they know
that what you're doing is right so they
were kind of my biggest supporters at
the time telling me to keep pushing on
and you know again well I got the haters
and just kind of and do what you think
is right because at the end of the day
people are going to realize it
eventually
and I had tons of people come after or
come up to me and years afterwards and
apologize and realize that what they did
was immature people who said the worst
things to me or told me to kill myself
or whatever those people would come up
to me and say I'm really sorry because
people mature they start to realize that
that's not okay dialogue even if you
totally disagree to someone so yeah
sadly we have a lot of people who don't
mature these sounds but that is that is
nice right here though
what about to support you that from you
guys I mean where your where your
friends that supported you willing to
publicly support you because that's
enough see that's another there's there
are certain things that's why I think
this is so interesting there are certain
trends with all of these whether it's
you taking an unpopular but principled
position or it's a guy like Brett
Weinstein at Evergreen there's all these
different people that come out come out
I mean it's a coming out in the way that
the same tactics happen every time and
in this case the idea that your your
friends or whatever won't back you
publicly but privately probably had no
problem doing it yeah I had friends who
came up to me or text me saying I
support you and I feel terrible for what
you're going through but I can't
associate myself with you and those
friends ended up trying to associate
with me later on in a way those are the
worst ones right because it's like if
someone just tells me to go after
yourself it's like big deal okay
whatever but the friends it's like am I
your shield am i you know gonna be like
am i the guy that's supposed to just be
out there while you sit quietly and do
nothing you're not helping me right yeah
I had one really good friend named
Brandon who supported me through it all
and would come over every this death
threat stuff started to happen right as
summer started which is the worst time
because in high school as a freshman you
don't really do anything during the
summer so you're just like at home
sitting looking at your Twitter thing
you know all these people want to kill
me or they think I'm the worst person in
the world so it's really nice to have
you know one friend who I could rely on
plus my family yeah I actually took a
little bit of a break from the town that
I lived in my dad even said you know
things got worse that we couldn't move
if that was necessary which I never
thought it was gonna be necessary it
never was but I took a little bit of a
break and went to my grandparents house
for a while just to get away from it all
because there was one time actually
my house when well two times once when
someone called and said they were gonna
come to my house and kill me she's got
an anonymous line to my home phone and
then a second time when I was watching a
movie and it was actually Ted and I was
trying to like have a fun night and
after all this stuff had been going on
and the someone knocked on the window
and was like flipping me off this is
like in the middle of the night as I was
sitting in my living room so I was
pretty scared to be at home for a little
while and so I went away for a little
bit yeah and it's interesting because I
don't want to belabor the point with you
and there's a lot of other that's the
important stuff I want to talk about but
I think that it's worth mentioning just
because so many people go through this
and more importantly you're on the other
side now yeah you made it you're doing
cool stuff and you survived then it's
just worth showing people that yeah well
usually you will survive yeah and I
think you know what was really big for
me is that it takes a strong person to
go through that but there are tons of
people going through the exact same
thing nationwide and I would even say
that there are some people on the left
side who go through the exact same thing
because it's not just it's not just
people on the left you have this nasty
attitude it's people on the right as
well and I think it's it's sickening
because even if you disagree with
someone wholeheartedly just stay quiet
if you really if you really are gonna be
that rude and that upset about it be
respectful be quiet that's kind of how I
would like to view things and so I think
to other people who are in similar
situations persevere through this is the
best thing that you can go through I
mean I I feel like I'm matured into a 45
or 50 year old when I was like 14 or 15
years old so I was able to really
progress and I think it actually might
be one of the best experiences of my
life
even though it was the one of the worst
experiences in my life in terms of
furthering myself it was one of the best
and I also think just knowing that if I
can persevere through it anyone can and
anyone should and standing up for your
viewpoints isn't gonna be easy but it's
totally worth it well said you know I
think we talked about this while we had
lunch a couple weeks ago yeah and I
think we talked about this but I told
you that I think my best professional
moment is also my worst professional
moment and it was with Larry elder
just bludgeoned be over the head with
facts and it was my worst cuz I wasn't
prepared it was my best because it
opened me up right and then I was like
oh new information new facts let's let's
explore that so so yeah getting through
something is pretty beautiful not that
I'm comparing that moment with Larry -
yeah and I think what I found is that it
actually what I did open up the eyes of
a lot of people who attacked me right
they event eventually apologized and if
they want to attack me and apologize
they want to have open their minds
either you know a couple years later
they're probably thinking back like oh
wow you know that was really terrible of
me but would they ever have thought
about that if that wouldn't have
happened they might have done the same
thing five years later it would be way
worse than doing it in high school so I
think that going through those
experiences in our what side you're on
is better and I don't think that it
should happen but it does it does help
you persevere yeah so that moment puts
you on the map now you know I started
following you on Twitter everywhere all
these people are following you you're
suddenly your voice is being heard were
you immediately involved in more
activism after that or is then it's you
had an interesting phase of like sort of
I could tell you were like very
frustrated with politics at times and
you were pissed at your own side a lot
and and you know and Trump and all that
flashing forward a little bit later but
what we got what was the next step let's
just get us to to where you're right now
yes I think he dealt with so much
negative political experiences that have
so many negative political experiences
that I wanted to do something positive
and I was sick of the partisan bickering
on both sides you know I've I have not
really changed any of my beliefs I think
both sides have just gone further and
further away from the middle which is
frustrating so I actually took a year
hiatus in high school my senior year
just to enjoy school and join my friends
and kind of graduate with with a fun
last experience but I couldn't really
stay away as long as I had hoped I was
thinking that I could probably stay away
through college as well yeah but I had
seen so many negative things that there
needed to be something done that was
positive and I was so you know again
sick of the partisan bickering that I
wanted to to get involved in something
that would benefit society and have a
decent dialogue
and won't generate complete hate from
both sides and I think that we need more
of that in politics a decent dialog and
if it has to has to happen on an easy
entry issue like the environment which
is what I focus on then so be it but I
would hope that that could transfer over
to really hotly contested issues - like
gun control or immigration right by the
way I would argue that actually talking
about the environment can be perhaps the
most hotly contested because anytime
anytime I've done anything on climate on
this show the amount of hate is bananas
on both sides right though of course it
shouldn't be right well we are all
living on this planet Earth so we all
care about it I would say help yeah a
vast majority of us it's a matter of
what you think is the best way to care
about it but well Kay so we're gonna get
to all your your work that's a big
answer so now it should be about is how
we all care about it but let's talk
about the different solutions yeah okay
so before we get to the solutions and
what you're doing now yeah what else I
think what people see a young
conservative there's still a piece of
them that they don't know what to make
sense of that how would you describe
conservatism in 2018 you gave me a
little bit of sort of what your initial
thoughts on it were when you were 10 but
right now what do you make of just sort
of the state of conservatism I think
that it's in a pretty tough spot I think
that what we've done as a movement is
just gone to everything that's anti left
and I don't think that's how it should
be and I don't think that it's
conservative I think a lot of the
principles I could go issue-by-issue but
there are there are a lot of principles
that I don't think are necessarily
conservative that are being pushed
forward now like I think there are some
things that Ronald Reagan went support
in today's time and I actually don't
think that he'd be successful as a
conservative in today's world I think
people would see him as to moderate to
wishy-washy
when actually he's he's the token
conservative right and I think that that
is frustrating and I think on the
environment and every other issue the
conservative goal is to be anti Hillary
anti Bernie anti left and sometimes we
forget to do our own solution and
sometimes we just go the exact opposite
end of the spectrum which is just as
dangerous as whatever the far left is
proposing yeah so I think that that's
were conservatism is now and I think
that is dangerous because if it keeps
going down that path I think the first
party to start realizing that they're
just
further and further away from the truth
and the middle are the first one to
realize that and changed course is going
to have a lot of success and I hope that
conservatives can realize that and start
to come back to what conservatism truly
is which is free markets limited
government it's not just bashing the
left it's trying to work with them as
you can and it's not always a far right
policy that's gonna be the answer yeah I
think that what conservatism was in 2008
or 2012 isn't exactly ideal but it's
more it's closer to where where it
should be than it is today
and I'm not saying Trump's to blame I
think it's just a huge movement that has
been sick of the left for so long and
sick of the radicalism of the left
they've done the exact same and I think
if we could just actually stay true to
our morals and take the higher ground I
think that it would be a lot better for
the country yeah it's interesting the
way you describe that that whichever one
stops first yeah because in my view and
it's funny because we come at this from
different places right like I was a
card-carrying lefty progressive liberal
I'm obviously a little older than you
but you came at it from from the other
side and it's like for me the stuff that
I focus on I've just seen the left
implode and if anything I would say it's
basically like a train that the brakes
are off they know the cliff is coming
but they're just gonna keep going and
going and going and keep pouring coal on
and let's go off the cliff and see what
happens
don't mention coal to the library
exactly but but to me that's what I've
seen there and I really spend a lot of
my life at least these last couple years
trying to correct that okay what I do
see and I think maybe maybe you agree
but maybe not is I do see more fertile
ground on the right for ideas that I can
now go to libertarian events and
conservative events and they hear my
differences and they're willing to hear
them out where I see virtually none of
that on the left do you think that's a
fair estimation even though I know
you're concerned obviously about what's
happening on the on the fringes of the
right I do a certain degree I think that
there is more and I think it's a
relative statement I don't think that
it's it's enough not I don't think it's
nowhere anywhere near enough I think a
perfect example is that any conservative
that doesn't agree with Trump 100% of
the time is kind of
shun you look at it about like CPAC or
how the RNC looks at things or something
like that and I think that what they
should be doing is embracing people of
all ideologies that come from the
conservative perspective and I think
when it comes to young people not every
young person is gung-ho for Trump not
every young person is gung-ho for a you
know a wall or whatever it may be
yeah and I think that conservatives need
to embrace the diversity more in a
leadership level I think like I college
campuses like the college Republicans
tend to be a more open and I think even
like a County Party would be more open
to different views obviously I don't
know every County Party and the millions
of counties that you have here but the
the fact that matter is I think that the
national landscape or at least the
national leaders are currently unlikely
to care about what the moderates think
or what even a typical conservative
thinks if they're not on a hundred
percent agreement
hmm and again I think conferences kind
of show that like the the CPAC
conference and I think that's been an
issue going on for years I mean the Log
Cabin Republicans were banned from CPAC
for I don't know how many years six
years and I think that we just need to
diversify the party and that's gonna
include non-christians it's going to
include LGBTQ people it's going to
include minorities and it's it's going
to include women and that's going to be
the future of the conservative party
along with the support that we have now
otherwise we're gonna be going down a
very wrong track record and if we keep
shaming all those people it's gonna be
tough what part of you doesn't say
you're a libertarian because I think I
know so much about what your ideas are
and you're trying to build all those
bridges I can give you a libertarian
reason for why all of those people
obviously should be included in a
conservative party or any party is there
anything about libertarian or do you
just not or is it you're just doing a
little political realism which I hear
from a lot of people is like I'm a
libertarian but the Conservatives and
the Republicans are the party that I can
work with most to get those ideas I
think if that's what you just said is
probably the best answer I have the
other thing that I would say is I think
that there are I disagree with
libertarians sometimes on the level of
government that should be involved I'm
still a limited government person I also
think myself
like a Reagan conservative but Reagan
wasn't anti-government in a lot of ways
he increased spending sometimes he did
taxes when it was necessary again I'm
limited government and when spending is
not possible we should never you know we
should never pursue spending if it can
be avoided
same with taxes and everything like that
but I also don't think that it's
completely off the table which some
libertarians do not all um but I think
that I probably issues wise agree more
libertarians especially on social things
maybe even immigration but I think
that's some of the just but overarching
government involvement I think the
government does have a place in some
things but it should be trying to help
the people instead of push things on the
people I which I think is is something
that made me make me a little bit more
moderate you've decided to put your stop
if the Republican or the right
conservative trains going off that way
you've decided to put your stake in the
ground and say we're gonna talk about
environment yep now even just hashtag
green GOP I mean people think the
Republicans the general consensus out
there if you ask the average person walk
down the street Republicans either hate
the environment or that or they want
endless pollution and they believe in
industry more than the earth I mean just
the all of this stuff that really
generally I find not to be true but they
haven't done a great job on answers yep
so first off how much do you think you
people your age generally care about the
environment yeah so I think you know
Millennials according to some recent
polling have showed that that's the most
important issue the environment is in
terms of when they go to the voting
booth the University of Texas and Pew
Research polls have shown that so I
think that that's a huge wake-up call to
conservatives that this is something
that an important voter base is
interested in tackling I know that most
conservatives are behind clean energy
especially when they're young
Millennials especially and then
obviously the left is as well
independent so I think clean energy
sustainability and just the general
environmental issues are very important
to young people and then a recent poll
just came out that showed that climate
change 57 percent of conservatives
Millennials want action
which is a pretty big amount and then
you've got 77% of Independence and then
84% of liberals so climate change is
also a very important issue to
Millennials so I think that all those
together kind of showcase why it's
important that conservatives start to
talk about these issues yeah how much of
this do you think is about belief
whether people actually believe the
science on this of whether manmade
climate change is real versus just what
the answers are so I know you're
focusing on the answers which I want to
get into but that basically meaning it's
either you have some set of people that
believe or don't believe but then you
have this other subset of people that
either think the government is the
answer or that the private sector is the
answer how do you even get those things
to meet in some way so I think that the
private sector and limited government is
the answer for these issues no matter if
you believe the science or don't believe
the science I think that we all like we
said earlier can agree that these issues
do matter that protecting the earth
doesn't matter no matter if climate
change is real or not we still have a
duty to protect the land that we've been
given by God and so I think that that's
something that can gel with most
conservatives and then with people on
the left or even independence if there
are kind of convinced that big
government is the answer which has been
kind of the only solution proposed so
far right it's our job as conservatives
to showcase why one that doesn't work
which is what we do focus on but two is
let's focus on one for a minute why
doesn't that work because I think most
people because most people don't think
critically about these things they go
okay I believe in climate change the
meme is out there yeah you believe in
climate change they always look to the
government so they go will I believe in
climate change what's the government
doing about it as opposed to the
alternatives that you're offering so
first how do you disconnect those two
things well the first problem is that
most people have only seen that as the
only answers yeah that's all if they
can't associate with environmental
progress which is a problem in itself
but why they haven't worked why the big
government hasn't worked on these issues
and some examples of that is the
Endangered Species Act which has only
taken 1% of the listings off the list
since 1982 and there have been a ton of
new species added and the reason that is
is because private landowners don't have
any rights of their land if they have
endangered species that's residing on
their land they got
come in and take it control it which is
really frustrating to landowners so what
they try to do is either move it off
their land or they just shoot it and
bury it so they can keep their land
which is again people just trying to
avoid big government for coming in and
taking their private property because
private property is one of the most
inherent rights that we have and
something that people really like to
protect just pause there because what a
whacked-out situation that is so if you
have some private land that has
something that's on this endangered
species list you might go ahead and kill
it yeah so that the government won't
know that it's there so they think even
if you don't want to you might love
animals I might love nature in a case
rewrite I would assume most of these
people would probably is the case you
might literally be killing in danger and
just so the government won't take your
land that's how warped this whole thing
is yeah and the the mantra is shoot bury
shut up that is a common thread when it
comes to endangered species and kind of
how private landowners look at it which
is really sad because like you said most
of them do care about animals they they
have farms they just have private
property and they love nature that's why
they have a place in nature they don't
want to shoot these places but they also
don't are these animals but they also
don't want to give up their land and
have it controlled by the government
until til whatever date they deem fit
and that would be really frustrating as
a private landowner who worked hard and
purchased the land it's it's just not a
good way to approach it and that is the
same problem that we've had with tons of
other issues is that when there's big
government involved there's always a
loophole to get around it there's always
a loophole to get around the punishment
and usually that loophole hurts the
environment because people don't respond
well to punishments they respond well to
incentives they respond well to doing
things on their own for moral good or
economic well-being and so I think
that's where the policies need to shift
and then another example the big
government not working is the Paris
climate Accords right it would be in
theory having every country come
together to try to help the environment
is a great idea right that that just
sounds nice and peachy I'm with you so
far sounds good okay
but then when you're making the people
who aren't polluting pay for it and the
people who are polluting go off
scot-free
and no countries are meeting their goals
and there's just a ton of money being
thrown around that
going to no benefit it has no benefit on
the environment and it's non-binding
there was Lin online there was literally
no mechanism to force anyone to do
anything so the US could do the bulk of
them the payments but we don't have any
mechanism to check whether anyone's
doing anything right and we're doing
those things in terms of cutting
emissions on our own it's technology
it's innovation it's hybrid cars which
the left loves to paint but where did it
come from the free market where the
electric cars come from the free market
where has Microsoft where have Microsoft
and Apple and all these companies who
have started to cut their emissions
they're doing it because of the market
they're doing it not because the
government is telling them to not
because the Paris climate Accords are
telling them to but because they know
it's the right thing to do the sensible
thing to do on an economic level and
even oil and gas companies are cleaning
up their acts because they know it's
necessary for PR but they also know that
being more environmentally sustainable
is going to be better in the long run
economically so it's not gonna be some
huge Accord that changes these things
especially when they're not pressuring
the right countries like China to
actually act and do something about it
it's gonna be countries deciding on
their own level what's gonna be right
and how they're gonna fix it if
countries want to come together and
create an actually cohesive plan that
works and gets things done and gives
some flexibility and doesn't just do
nothing then that's great that should be
something that happens and something
that President Trump should actually
encourage a beneficial Accords Paris
climb quartz doesn't do that and that's
an example of the government failing
yeah I like that you're linking this
directly to technology because it also
it's sort of like you know 20 years ago
if there was a soil spill somewhere in
some remote area of Antarctica most
likely we wouldn't have heard about it
you know unless it was just massive one
like the Exxon Valdez or something but
like a lot you could get away with a lot
but these days literally everyone in the
Western world at least has a cell phone
right workers at these places if there's
a leak can videotape it anonymously
upload it to Twitter and then everyone
finds out so it's so obvious to me that
technology is the answer here that you
know because everyone's always afraid if
you get rid of any of these losses what
I hear from from the left all the time I
here this from from Bill Maher's I'm if
you if you get rid of these laws they're
gonna start polluting the lake right
right next to the to the factory and
it's like help actually know you're
accountable and that's just the truth
and something that I love to point out
is that technology is the reason why
emissions ours have started to go down
technology is the reason why we have so
many amazing opportunities to fix the
environment there's no big government
regulation that's able to cut emissions
like technology can and one thing that's
really amazingly pointed out by one of
our board members Todd Meyers is that
think about how much the iPhone itself
can do in conservation and climate you
are able to control your heating and
energy costs from your phone turn off
the energy when you don't use it and
control it completely from your phone
instead of having to run back to your
house before you go on a long you know
vacation or whatever and then just
saying okay I'll screw it I'll just
leave my on my lights or whatever it is
yeah that's helping the environment a
ton and each year more effective cars
come out with you know more miles per
the gallon or electric and hybrid or
electric is starting to really start to
take over which is really exciting
that's technology that's not the
government and technology and
environmental progress go hand-in-hand
and you look at oil spills or you look
at nuclear waste or whatever all those
have improved dramatically over the past
couple decades because these companies
know that has to happen people will find
out about it and never give them
business again and basically shut down
their business if more accidents start
to happen I mean look at what BP went
through mm-hmm
BP is one of the best stewards on the
environment out of gas companies ever
since then because they know that they
can't have that type of a situation
again yeah they can't have how many days
was that thing leaking and there was the
live camera yeah right everyone knew
about it I mean if you have any American
they would know about the BP oil spill
where do you guys stand on nuclear just
a couple weeks ago I had Mike
Shellenberger in here I love myself okay
cool so this is interesting then so you
are a conservative with some libertarian
leanings yeah he's running for governor
of California as a Democrat you know he
started as an independent but I think
just for because of a little political
realism he's running as a Democrat
but obviously for nuclear power and he's
trying to erase some of the stigma to it
which there's obviously a tremendous
amount you know just necessary Kashima
was just a couple years ago right so
there so that's interesting so you like
this guy yeah Michael Shellenberger is a
perfect example of what Democrats need
to aspire to be and that is common sense
able to work with both sides isn't
afraid to just stray away from the
talking points of the left which is
which are usually incorrect especially
I'm like nuclear nuclear is supposed to
be the most dangerous and harmful when
in reality it's kind of a future and
Michael Shellenberger knows that so
Michael Shellenberger is great and I
think that California would be much
improved by having a governor as
moderate as him you know we're gonna get
me Gavin Newsom right but what can you
do see how owners great and I think
he'll be there for another four years
hopefully after this year but yeah I
think nuclear is is an important part of
an all-of-the-above energy strategy that
America needs to start adopting and
nuclear is the least amount of accidents
out of any energy sector they're really
improving of technology I mean there's
only been like three nuclear accidents
in history everyone knows about them
because they're terrible but there
haven't been any since Japan and all of
them were avoidable all them were
avoidable none of them have happened in
the United States because the United
States has been careful about it and
these companies are careful and it's
almost become impossible with recent
technology to have an accident like that
unless you really deliberately trying to
hurt the area around you and trying to
release the waste is it partly because
of government regulation that our
nuclear plants haven't had problems can
you give any credit in that way I I
don't know enough about how those
regulations have worked but all I know
is that regulations from the government
have shut down nuclear progress because
right now that discouraging nuclear
plants are being built and none are I
don't think any are being built
currently because the United States
government is trying to phase it out
when really it's going to it's clean
it's effective it cuts emissions and
it's very powerful and I know that I
think the vast majority of the changes
have
from these companies realizing that
there's no way for them to succeed if
they aren't careful with their
operations and they also know that I
mean unless you're a terrible human
being you don't want to put nuclear
waste and you don't give everyone cancer
and have them die unless you're terribly
and being so I think that that's also
just part of the thing and and new
technology is making nuclear more
effective and less dangerous and I and I
think it's safe to say that nuclear is
almost 100 percent foolproof at this
point in time but you can't always go on
the best intentions of these people
because yes I agree most people don't
want people that I've cancer and do all
that stuff but you know business owners
just like government regulators often do
shady things so part of the issue here
is that you can't always control the
business owner yep the industrialist but
you also can't always control the
government so there isn't a perfect
answer here right no there's not and I
think that there are there it is the
duty of the government to protect the
people to a certain degree I mean you're
not yet they have to ban murder and they
have to ban certain things so it's not
so that's not lawful and I think that
certain basic protections can be put in
place on nuclear to make sure that these
companies are making sure that it's safe
they shouldn't be so stringent that you
can't start one up or that you get
punished for you know what X Y or Z
unless it's a terrible a breach of
knowledge so I think that that's
something that the government can play
into I think it's gonna be more up to
the technology and the business owners
to have the answers to make nucular
better with a couple basic nuclear
government regulations what kind of
traction
are you guys getting sort of with
mainstream Republicans and and with
people that are in office right now
because these seem to be the answers
that I would love these guys to take but
they've been very hesitant to take yeah
so one thing before we even launched
this organization I met with a lot of
Congress men and women and they on the
Republican side and they said that they
cared about these issues they wanted to
tackle them but the only reason they
didn't was visiting here from their base
they only heard from the Sierra Club and
the League of Conservation Voters and
the fact of the matter is those people
are never gonna be their voters and
matter how they come out on
environmental issues so we think that
there is a latent base of support
at the base but with legislators who
want to lead on these issues but they
just need some pushing so I think that
that's something that the conservative
movement is ready for and there are a
good handful of 2225 current Republican
Congress men and women who are already
leading on these issues it's just a
matter of getting that number up and
starting to have those legislators hear
from their base talking about the base
the base is totally ready especially
Millennials like I was talking about
earlier with some of the polling that's
been done basically all young
conservatives care about the environment
one way or the other
no matter if it's climate change-related
or not they're ready for clean energy
they're ready for all the above energy
they're ready for common-sense
conservation practices and so we have
had such success with the base that we
have 37 out of 50 College Republican
state chairs on board with what we're
doing with more to come in the next few
months we are working with countless
College Republican and turning-point USA
and young Americans for freedom chapters
across the country to spread some of
these things we have the support of all
the youth leaders on the right charlie
Kirk Chandler Thornton of the College
Republicans grants trouble as young
Americans for freedom it's really been
welcoming and we haven't really gotten
too much flack from the right because
they're so ready for something like this
with common sense solution it's
interesting does this feel like a little
bit of a perfect storm right now for you
guys with what's going on on college
campuses I mean you know I had Charlie
in here from Turning Point a couple
weeks ago and I did the guy is just
knocking it out of the park every day
what they're doing it's just incredible
to me even for the things that I
disagree with them on yeah it's like
you've really built this grassroot thing
I was just at the student for liberty
conference a couple weeks ago I thought
what they were doing is great I think
what you're doing is right that suddenly
it seems like there's this like backlash
against the hysteria of the left and
what you would say is also the the
hysteria or at least in environmental
terms the backward thinking of the right
that it's kind of led to a nice moment
here where whoa maybe there are some
other answers yeah I think college
students are so sick of being painted as
anti-environment and they don't really
know where to ant that what the answer
is and conservative Senate really
provided the answer they just go on and
go after the left which is great we need
to criticize the left on their
environmental policies that haven't
worked we also have to provide our own
answers and I think you're you hit on
something perfectly and that college
students are always looking
were more knowledge and to be more
active in issues that they care about
turning-point USA has done that ton of a
ton of other organizations have begun to
really activate young people and the
environment is something that's been
kind of left out so far and that's why
turning-point in college Republicans are
so supportive as because they realize
that's an important part of their
mission is to garner attention and
activism from people that may really
care about the environment and may be a
little bit hesitant to be active unless
the Conservatives are more active on
that issue so I think that is a perfect
storm and there's no other group like us
out there there's no group advocating
for conservative environmental solutions
we're doing it focused on Millennials
but there's nobody doing it for any age
group
yeah and so we're happy to work with
anybody but I think that it's perfect
and then also conservatives are looking
for a way to talk to liberals on some
issues on college campuses college
campuses are so divided that you know
you bring in a speaker even if they're
the most moderate speaker and there's
protests you know up the wazoo you know
there's there's no there's no end to it
even if you bring in John Kasich you're
gonna get half you know right half of
your school out there protesting saying
he's a white nationalist right so even
though most people would say that maybe
he identifies more at the Democratic
Party now so I think sometimes they do
it when that Dave Rubin guy shows up
it's very busy it's crazy so I
understand that one but yeah but I think
you know if we can have a dialogue with
people on the left then showcase that we
actually do care about the environment
we're just not we're anti left on
everything we just want to work with you
guys on actual common-sense solutions
not what you guys are pushing but
something that maybe both sides can
agree on what I've found at my own
college campus because I go to the
University of Washington in Seattle is
that I've talked to a bunch of typical
people who would show up to your protest
maybe even an Tifa and they've found
that okay this is kind of fun there's a
conservative cares about the environment
that's cool I didn't know they existed
and I'm like well they're everywhere
almost every conservative it you've ever
talked to or protested accounts cares
about the environment but we need to
start having that dialogue and I think
that slowly it can sort of start to
bring together some of the divide on
colleges I would imagine that in a place
like University of Washington look you
got Seattle there that's obviously
progressive who's but I would
there's so many people there that live
suburban lives and out there in nature
and all those things where they have
this strange dichotomy now they've been
told that the Republicans hate the
environment they love the environment
but they also love freedom because they
want to be on their own land all that so
to me that's very fertile ground it's
just I would imagine every place that
the Pacific Northwest is probably the
perfect place to start using this as the
incubator it is and some of the
conservative leaders in Washington State
were pioneers for environmental progress
nationally
you've got former governor Dan Evans who
created the Department of the ecology
which was what was the EPA was founded
after which is supposed to be a limited
government but important agency that
only stepped in when necessary it's gone
far past those bounds but that's what he
had done and he was a conservative a lot
of the public land has been named after
him because of all of his contribution
to conservation in the state you've got
a lot of former senators and congressmen
and women even though some current ones
who are leading on these issues from the
Republican side because they realize
they live on this land they're in the
mountains they're in the Cascades or the
Olympics and they really care and I
think that it's a different state for
that and then if you take away Seattle
it's a very conservative state I didn't
even say that about a lot of states but
in their big cities but in Washington a
lot of those mountainous rural areas
that are constantly impacted by the
environment or they live in the
environment itself are conservative
people who want to have leadership on
this issue but just don't really know
where to find it and only know what you
said of the big government interactions
that can happen and you've got the
Seattle mayor and the Washington
governor who claim to care about the
environment but if nothing ever happens
and I think that a lot of people are
sick of those things especially in a
state like Washington where the
environment matters yeah so where are
you at with Trump on all this because
okay we talked about climate Paris
climate Accords he got us out of that so
I sense you're you're happy about that
his regulation situation I think they're
cutting something it changes all the
time but if they're cutting a ton of
regulation for every new one that they
pass I think you're generally for that
but I know you're not a big Trump guy
that's probably putting it mildly right
yes so where do you think he falls on
the environmental stuff
I think I actually haven't been as
annoyed with his environmental policies
as I would have thought before he was
elected or even right after you selected
which I think is a good thing but I
think part of the problem that he falls
into which is what most conservatives
fall into is that they criticize the
left they might like deregulate they
might remove some protections or
whatever but what are they gonna do as
an answer what's gonna be their solution
that isn't anti left or that you know
whatever whatever the solution is that
they're cutting what are they gonna
replace that with and I think that Trump
hasn't done a good enough job just like
most conservatives recently of doing
that swap of policy and in terms of if
you're going to remove the protection
here how are you gonna protect it on the
other side so what is that answer that
you'd like to see well I would like to
see an all-of-the-above energy policy
that is not focused on subsidies or tax
breaks we need to remove those from the
clean energy sector in general I was
actually not a fan of Trump's tariffs on
solar because while they have a ton of
tax break so does oil and coal and we
need to just put them on an even level
playing field because conserves care
about the free market I said the free
market compete and if soar is the worst
thing in the world and it's just being
prompted by subsidies let's slap the
free market take it out if the coal if
coal is done let's have cool coal get
taken out the free market needs to just
dominate on the energy sector and I
think that the president needs to focus
on that would you leave a lot of that to
the state so for example a place like
California where the sun is shining
you know 367 days a year
you'd before California's doing whatever
it feels it's regulated to say exactly
exactly I think it should be up to the
states and their different states that
need different things right like Iowa
and different states in the Midwest get
a lot of wind so so you know wind energy
makes a ton of sense there are states
like Washington that have a lot of water
and hydropower makes a lot of sense
Arizona and Texas are two of the leading
states on solar they're conservative
states and usually solar is identified
as a liberal thing right but those
governors have totally implemented solar
because they know it works and they know
it's effective in their states soared
would not really work that well in
Seattle right
so it just depends on the state and I
think that unless the free market can
decide that and have different states
figure out what they need it's gonna be
really frustrating because it's gonna be
really frustrating for states like Texas
and Arizona in California who now are
gonna have to pay a premium for solar
when it's been really effective there
and now there's a tariff on it and an
unnecessary tariff and then you know
what what are they gonna do they're
gonna have to figure out a different way
to get their energy for those areas that
they're losing the solar from so I've in
solar panels it's not like the ones that
are already there can just stay there
they have like a ten year lifespan a lot
of the time so a lot of them need to be
replaced and if there's a new tariff
that's damaging so I think that it just
needs to be left up to the states and I
think it also needs to be a lot of
deregulation less subsidies less tax
breaks on the energy side yeah so a
couple minutes ago you mentioned that
the EPA has gone well past its mandate
yeah I think this is an interesting one
to sort of end on because I think it's a
good place to start when you're talking
to people because everyone I think if
you talk to the average person that that
wants to do good by the environment they
automatically think the EPA is good
right it's just Environmental Protection
Agency it sounds good how could that
possibly be bad what does that actually
mean that they've gone beyond their
original mandate and why does it keep
growing and growing and growing they're
supposed to enforce the law not create
the law and the EPA has gone to the
point where they are creating their own
laws and they have been incredibly
incredibly regulatory and have not
helped the environment at all what
they're supposed to do is enforce what
Congress passes and what the American
people want an environmental protection
for example some Republicans put
together a really amazing coastal
barrier resiliency act well Reagan as
president and the EPA enforces that
that's what the EPA is supposed to do
not create their own regulations and
says you can't do this you can't do this
you can't do this let that be up to the
states and the local areas and if it
needs to happen on the national level
let's have a vote on it
mm-hmm and I think the EPA has become
more of a punishment organization rather
than a let's help the environment get
people to do the right thing and only
enforce the law that's really what it's
supposed to be
it's not become that at all that being
said they they enforce the law so those
things need to stay in place you can't
just remove that but they have created
their own really unnecessary regulatory
reforms that have just not worked is
that just the best argument for small
government in general that we just
create these things these entities that
are well-intentioned usually I think
usually most of them are well you know
Department of Education sounds good
we're going to educate people
environmental projector we're going to
protect the environment that these are
usually well-intentioned but then just
because of the way the government works
because of gridlock and Washington
because of all the money poured in they
become these albatrosses that they've
pretty much never were intended to be
yeah I think that that kind of leads
into a bigger issue as of how do we keep
that from happening
because I think most people will agree
that there needs to be some sort of
government we're not just gonna be
governed by ourselves we need to have
some sort of government and but it needs
to be held accountable so I don't know
how often they need to look at where
these agencies have been going but
obviously a lot of them have gone way
past what they need to be doing the
Department of Education is a perfect
example of really actually ruining the
education system in the United States
and EPA has gone way past what it needs
to be doing we need to have a way to
check on these areas frequently and make
sure that they're sticking to what they
were created to do and not going past
that and being held accountable for it
and I'm sure that happens it definitely
happens with with every new
administration but nothing really ever
changes and I think that it's Trump and
every president from here on out that
needs to analyze when they get into
office where these agencies are at how
we can cut down or increase if that's
necessary what they're doing and I think
that that could be a really good answer
but a bigger answer is to have state
governments and local leaders and local
governments as well as businesses do
their own thing on these issues to prove
to the government the federal government
that we don't need restrictions we don't
need regulations we can do it ourselves
and we're far more effective and I think
that that's the answer rather than
waiting on Congress to do something well
that is a great closing statement my
friend but I gotta ask you one more
because it's so obvious to me you've
become a master at what what you care
about and you're trying to do good work
and that you actually are affecting
people so what year are you running for
office just give me a ballpark
maybe 2036 Wow usually when I've asked a
few people this they punt the question
you did not punt I didn't
for more on banking at his budding
political campaign check him out on
twitter at benji backer
[Music]
you